young s'est excusé et aujourd'hui c'est
robin des toits sur le masne werder de
gazole parce que ça fait longtemps que
c'est ta femme tu werder et ça fait du
bien
1 ou pas trop parce que je prends des
coups de couteau dans le dos bon
visionnage mais bouquet mais qu'at t
quoi médias pitié du chant mais
d'afrique e mail j'apparais attaché
mains mais j'ai cligner des yeux mongai
que j'étais déjà mort à chaque aime quoi
ces choses qui a un peu quand même mais
ça va le fils de chien bah ouais c'est
n'importe quoi cette fois boîte à part
les tumeurs direct elle attend à droite
sur étagère boleadores selecçao 7 les
flics ça c'est pas moi je te dis je te
jure c'est pas moi je me rends non le
peleton de tête
moi je fais une fête privée voilà ceux
qui veulent venir acheter vos tickets à
l'entrée juste là où un homme sur le
tableau c'est lui qui les soirs amputé
j'ai pu sortir son nom mais c'est
beaucoup quoi c'est la bronzette
j'ai sorti mon couteau s'en va exprès je
suis trop day samsung événementiel a
déjà fait qu'il y ait moins de profits
le bleu sont balancés québec c'est
québec
non cette équipe et je trouve pas le
cadre
par contre je québec
ses cheveux attends je fais à poster ça
fait google et yahoo
il se prenait pas comment y voit surtout
un bon gars parce qu'ils hésitent plus
rien tartas pour s'adapter
il était trop tard pour regarder j'en
fais pas qui est équipé thales avec
cette année aller
cette fois j'allume le tank bas ok c'est
moi vas-y vas-y calden vasic enemy coco
badine on est jamais berlin
j'sais pas comment on va là au retour de
bâton carto juliette c'est beau c'est
hugo xingu dont sept indiens c'est
direct et elles gagnent entre lucas
jackson double zoulou mer ont dû signer
mais j'ai fait sentir mais tu as voulu
faire quoi la logan lucas oui la petite
coupe de cheveux pour la même chose je
vous jure que c'est mika technique
j'avais raison c'est raté au nom de
merde et badauds tu as voulu ouvrir le
volet et banda mon gars watts à bavois
là bonjour j'ai des milliers
je veux sochaux je vais me douche et je
reviens j'aime faire ça ne s'est pas
roulé car c'est par ici
au delà elle avoir un serveur qui était
violemment inscrivit deux tiers des cas
je suis bon je vais passer en miniature
pas survie qu'à moi je vends des bananes
avec des bières tout cas pas du tout
alors à l'eau je me protège
cette badano protège mal à me protéger
je sors du salut les gars salut je veux
mourir en berne
c'est un nouvel algorithme de tubes
algorithmes tout à fait
pourquoi tu te caches tu as là bas il
s'est abattu cette fois c'est pas moi
pourquoi tu le regardes de couteau si
j'avais couteau au total sortie de route
a fait dans sa carrière
webb s'est abattue et non beach quartier
c'est la technique du sétois
non mais oui bah ça c'est possible et je
suis quand même
gsk chez moi pour des bijoux brodés ou
quoi c'est pas moi mais s'il tue la
terreur que jean laville moi qui suce
pas le cas soit mais je sais qu'ils
croient que ces voix là tu crois que
c'est moi parce que je suis bah ouais
mais celle où je sélectionne un peu
bizarre je veux bien suivi de près des
avis mais quand même mais on sait
ducasse et lucas toiture est la toile et
a mis le temps mais j'avais serment qui
sont sortis fébrile je ne vienne pas
fébrile moi je parie que c'est qu'avec
des cas tu me fais quoi tu me confirmer
ou pas vas-y fais-le confiance je suis à
droite la non mais qui atteint trouve un
peu trop à gauche qui vous intéressent
c'est pas moi a débloqué à mes
sympathies spasmes non non non non mais
le mec pas contenté d'un bug c'est
vraiment pas drôle c'est parce que j'ai
perdu je suis pas un connard ok mais je
pense à un passage à la base je savais
que tu savais que j'étais fébrile dans
leur boîte descend dans mon cahier
d'histoire maintenant qu'à tricheurs
store labrecque stop lightning doit bien
faire tache de sang mais j'ai de taches
de sang du cwatupe à des choix des
bananes la cuisse contre salzbourg
la madone à protéger loué soit les
balades banana café le petit verre
pourquoi fait il ça alors je te vois
déjà qui le protège et accuse madame
bonjour oui non loué soit la banane
j'ai encore bloqués [ __ ] bombon seine
n'ont rien c'est bravo tu fais quoi
ce panache si je suis bloqué mais je
peux jouer mais je peux pas bouger
ouais ça allait aller 6 km on est tous
sur toi mon gars ont dit non
[Musique]
c'est mika c'est michael ganne il m'a
tuer smic bagad monga [ __ ] tu fais
quoi
mais tu fais que wasquehal b et c jamais
chez lui qu'un le meurtrier aux chiens
j'arrive de ses mécanos tu as déjà
c'était à moi tiens prends tes bagages
j'ai dit et je vous remercie
allez allez j'ai presque aignan question
de venir sur le tour avec moi tout à
fait une table de chevet mes sincères
condoléances à toute la famille et voilà
j'en sais déjà fin de cette vidéo ce
soir s'il aura plus ce qu'elle n'était
pas allé mais ça va rempiler à chaque
fois je pense pas à vis à vis de
résoudre aussi avec mon ski des
meurtriers a bien évolué ensemble tech
offre une nouvelle vidéo tient tout le
monde
ils n'ont pas cette fois bah oui j'ai tu
t'attaches au pc puisque tu t'envoles à
chaque fois
[Musique]